[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a little camera
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yes
one second let me region
hi uh
am I audible am I visible
hi good evening everyone I see
participants coming in so
let's give them one more minute to join
and we'll get started
hello everyone welcome
welcome everyone
glad to see you all here
right let's get started
uh good evening and good morning to
everyone who has joined from different
parts of the world uh it gives me
immense pleasure in welcoming you your
family and friends present here to the
Third online convocation ceremony for
the year 2022 hosted by simply learn in
association with Caltech ctme
I am Naveen srinivasan senior program
manager at simply learn responsible for
Learners success for ctme and other
technology programs
first and foremost I would like to
congratulate everyone here who have
achieved something which many claim to
be near to be impossible
I can understand that there is an area
of excitement among everyone uh this air
of excitement is all about your family
friends your faculty the management at
Caltech and simply learn every single
person present here today is very proud
of
I'm sure many here are excited for the
future and at the same time have a huge
sense of relief that all the hard work
and struggle is done and now you take a
back seat and just relax and enjoy the
moment
now let me remind you of the journey
that uh brought you to this Monumental
milestone
for the past six to eight months you
have such a weekend sessions eight hours
of live classes every weekend
you have spent hundreds of hours
absorbing knowledge through live virtual
classes the online self-learning videos
and doing 20 plus assessments and
projects
you completed the Capstone project
through this knowledge and the acquired
skills and now you're here many
congratulations for that
it honestly requires a lot of commitment
and passion to achieve this your shared
determination and support from your
family and friends of course does not go
unnoticed
I would like to take this moment to
applaud and appreciate each one one of
you
and also like to thank your family and
friends
for their continued support in making
your story a successful room
so moving on to the chief guest for
today
I'm delighted to introduce our first
guest of Honda for today Mr Mike Ash
is the program director at Caltech ctme
Mike is extremely passionate about the
new age Technologies and how the impact
of it would make the society and the
world will live in a better place
these are Harvard Business alumni and he
has also been associated with many
Fortune hundred companies formulating
competitive strategies guiding them to
Industry shift in terms of digitization
globalization and consumer preferences
we are immensely happy to have you here
Mike so a few words to the learners
thank you and welcome everybody uh we're
really excited to be here uh for this uh
this is the third virtual convocation
for the Learners between us simply learn
and and caltex Center for technology and
management education this is a
relationship that's been in place for
three years now and it's it's incredible
just to talk to the participants in the
program the success stories that they've
had
the good feedback that they give us
about improving programs
um and and how to make things more
relevant for them and we're excited and
I want to Welcome All of You graduates
into the Caltech ctme family
um you know this family as I said has
been growing over the last three years
uh we're really proud
um and being Caltech we'd love to have
people who are
sincere motivated and very curious about
learning new things
and
this is these are programs the
postgraduate programs and the boot camps
are ones that require a commitment and
you've all demonstrated that and you've
all recently completed your
that long journey that Naveen just put
out there
so we really want to thank you not just
for investing your time but also uh your
family has been a part of this to give
you the space to be able to learn and
many of you your employers doing the
same and making commitments to weekends
and and learning sometimes even more
than
about what's required
so your demonstration of of grit and I
love that word
um and you'll hear it in in these
presentations uh that grit to learn and
stay committed
um and being able to ask for help with
the help is needed
um
that's gonna that's gonna help you grow
both uh personally and professionally
so uh we're really glad to see that
so on behalf of the entire department of
ctme we're part of the engineering and
applied science at Caltech uh all the
program alumni over the last three years
uh we really uh wish the best to
everyone and in all your future
endeavors
so thank you again
Naveen hi thank you Mike for the
wonderful Woods
now what gives me immense pleasure in
introducing our sponsor for today our
chief business officer and co-founder
kashab talal
during his time he is spearheaded's
several initiatives and has been a major
driver intro to success being an IIT IIM
alumni kasham truly believes in
delivering world-class products and have
always been working from getting from
better to best
mashup is extremely passionate about
this program and has been a key factor
to the success of this program at simply
learn we are extremely happy to have you
here Kasha a few words to the partisan
please
hey thanks Naveen and hi Mike great to
uh share this forum with you as well I
think I would like to start with a you
know deep and heartfelt congratulations
to all the participants I think it's
great to see all of you graduating from
the different uh technology-based
programs that we have in partnership
with Caltech ctme
um I think what you know a lot of us
have touched upon but I would like to
reiterate that I think while going
through the different profiles of all
the different Learners from different
walks of life all of you you know there
has been so much of balancing I think
all of us have busy lives most of you
have a day job you are working and a
full-time role there are family
commitments and and with all of that
going on to be able to pull out the time
for so many months consistently and and
follow your passion uh it it just feels
wonderful to see that it's paid off and
you all are completing the program and
and you know hopefully this knowledge
will really arm you to move on to
greater things in life
I think what is also very exciting and
it's a privilege to be part of this
journey that we've been able to curate
and build some of these programs
together with Celtic ctme on different
Technologies which are transforming the
world right so right now everything is
being turbocharged with digital
Technologies uh the programs that we uh
have seen you all go through in cloud
devops data Ai and various other skill
sets I think these are the technologies
that are going to build the world of the
future
again would wish you a
you know hearty congratulations and
really hope that you will be able to use
this knowledge to really accelerate your
careers and open up new opportunities uh
which would open up new exciting
chapters in your life and your Journeys
congratulations once again and thanks
thanks very much
thank you so much for the wonderful
words
so moving on so uh
today is indeed a celebration a
celebration to acknowledge your hard
work your dedication and your intent in
successfully completing the PG program
with Caltech ctme and simply learn
before we get to the graduates will it
not be trained to hear from your fellow
participants on how they felt about this
program
there are few participants who have
volunteered to share their Learning
Journey with us so I would like to call
upon uh Manisha who has completed the
pgp in cloud computing with us to share
a few words
and attend if you can
I have Manish yeah
Manish you are one of the panelists so
if you can
yeah yes Manish we can hear you yes we
can hear you
my morning uh evening as applicable
um so I've been uh I'm Manish Agarwal um
I have been working in networking
industry for around 20 years now I've
been learning uh gently project
management pmps drum and all all that
stuff
um in my past decades but then recently
what I observed was a lot of
applications that that we were building
were moving to cloud cloud platform so
uh it at some point of time it become
became imperative for me to start
learning these new technologies to be
more effective and
um
to be more connected at work
um I think the first preference would be
to start learning on my own so I started
with some YouTube videos and then couple
of other platforms uh although I don't
have any complaints about those videos
and content but I was not able to
complete them because of lack of a plan
and then this is when I thought that
okay let me let me start and do a
dedicated program
um I did I did research for a couple of
weeks and then iPhone simply learn
good reviews shared by a lot of Learners
online and then I enrolled for the
program the program stood up to my
expectation I think my first
first eight weeks where I learned about
AWS uh the best thing about that
sessions was it was Hands-On I think
that gave me a lot of confidence that
yes this thing can be learned
um and uh that that was a turning point
in my Cloud Journey that may be
comfortable with cloud and then lot of
knowledge with self-learning videos and
quizzes and then along with that I was
able to I think there is a lot of into
at the start so I was able to complete
my AWS Cloud certification and AWS
machine learning certification as well
um however okay now I think with time I
started with Azure but I was not able to
match the pace with work
but then I approached simply learn to
help me on how I can catch up so simply
learn help me move to another cohort
which helped me to catch up on Azure as
well I am planning to complete my Azure
104 and the 305 shortly so overall my
experience was great definitely I think
it was it was a major turning point
because of of a lot of other ecosystems
are also connected to cloud like if you
have to learn machine learning AI
correct all those
compute processing is is moving to Cloud
so Cloud would become a baseline going
forward and then this program has helped
me start my new journey and then it is
up to me to keep walking
sure great great success story Manish uh
we are glad that we were able to help
you out in kind of having the knowledge
that you have in Cloud today
thank you so much Manish thank you it's
great to hear from you
next we have uh shikib Ali
from PHP cloud computing as well
she came
can you hear us
okay so in interest of time
we will settle back to Shakib so zoom in
from pgp FSD
zoom in if you're here
and I don't know if you can
make zoom in the participant uh panel is
sorry
but um can you hear me now yes we can
hear you well soon oh okay so um thank
you guys very much for having me
um so
I know for a fact that this achievement
was one of the most significant
um achievement in my life
so before taking this class
um unlike other people I guess I had
zero knowledge of computer
and I know that uh I knew the
Proficiency in software or programming
is essential during this area era
um of its data technology blockchain and
iot whether I work in manufacturing I.T
or health or other fields and I took
both that web development
um and honestly it was a lot more than I
expected it's your background but most
importantly now I can make a website
that I never thought I could so thank
you simply learn and support uh simply
learn support and um ctme
but um nothing came easy uh there are
times that I doubted myself but I can um
say that hard work pays off
currently I'm working in the same
company I did not change my career
um so uh I'm
um I'm into more design and um
uh mode maintenance
but um uh but everything I learned
turned out to be beneficial stuff or in
my current job like for example I made
from browser that shows daily attendance
rate which you can plug in uh to your
company's Network so that everyone can
see a very long time
and they realized that knowledge that I
gained in this journey is not limited to
learning developing websites but it gave
me Foundation to tackle issues such as
inefficiency
and I'm willing to learn as much in the
future to serve
um others better
and like me some of my co-workers might
not have had complete picture of how the
future will play out but I believe
um in one of the speeches that Steve
Jobs mentioned
um you cannot connect the dots looking
forward but you can only connect them
looking backwards so you must trust that
the Dutch will somehow connect in your
future and I'm sure your dedication in
this journey will someday be one of the
significance that the connect to your
success um thank you
thank you Suman I hope you guys have
kind of build more applications more
apps uh and make this world a better
place thank you so much
thank you
next we have uh Ganguly
who's also from pgp in full stack
development
yes I can see you can unmute yourself
Dean can you hear me yes I can hear you
hey uh good morning everyone uh my name
is
pgp FSD uh batch and um
it has been a great experience and it
was a good introduction by EU Naveen and
it uh when I was reminiscing those uh
long eight-month uh waking up on time on
Sunday uh and Saturday uh
uh the amount of support that my family
had extended selflessly to me because it
requires a lot of family support because
uh I I'm based in the U.S on our classes
started from 9 30 to 1 30 so basically
all the groceries and all those things
and it was not just uh not just one-off
it was like every other every every
every week almost every weekend the
reason why I joined those course was
because look I I work in a Manufacturing
Company in the IIT Department of a
manufacturing company based on the
United States and I have been working
with technology that can be
that can be termed as old based on the
current uh
current uh Market scenario so things
like angular or spring they were new to
me a year back
I would like to thank simply learn for
uh
um designing this course curriculum in
which uh
um it was it was a it was a jam-packed
course and it touched a lot starting
from core Java basics of HTML CSS
JavaScript then spring
um so it was it was it was kind of a lot
to deal with but uh we have the some of
the instructors were really good I must
say that and there are some which I'll
never forget the they were really good
and overall the assignments and
um the live coding one of the things
which uh I I really enjoyed and that's
the that's another reason why I joined
this course is uh the instructors used
to do it in front of us so we can see
how it's going on instead of uh showing
us something that was pre-cooked
the learning success managers
helped us many times where
they would uh they would really
understand
um where we are coming from what our
problems are and each and every time uh
all problems that were reported uh had
been taken care of so that is something
I I must say
um
and lastly uh well uh I cannot say this
made me an expert well there is you you
can never be an expert in life that is
however it has given me a direction in
which I can proceed and I now know what
to do and uh how to take myself forward
that will be it
thank you so much that was a great
Insight from you and many
congratulations again on completing the
one of the toughest tracks that we have
today
thank you so much
next we have uh Lakshmi Gupta KV who has
completed the program in pgp in cloud
computing
sbcu as a panelist if you get unmute and
speak
uh hi can you hear me yes I can hear you
well
hi good afternoon good evening and good
morning everyone this is Lakshmi Gupta I
hold with five years of experience in VR
in a list
and total in 10 years however like I
think uh Manish has read my mind uh
rightly he bought Azure of which cases
which was really helpful for me in fact
in the real learning and implementing
the same in my organization as well
however it was more of a Tiny Steps I'm
not into a full-fledged uh architecting
role
but I'm sure with this confidence that I
have learned in simply learned
collaborated with the Caltech University
I'm sure I'm going to achieve the Great
Heights thank you so much uh simply
learn and Caltech especially the master
classes was really wonderful by Alex who
has taken on the cloud adoption
and I would like to thank you in John
Lewis made the market last more
wonderful and meaningful in terms of
knowledge sharing I'm sure looking
forward for those selective classes as
well
but uh there was one regret that I wish
the master classes should not end at
least for a year
that that please keep you invited we
will keep you invited that that would be
it is the benefit of all
yeah
thank you thank you so much because it
is great that we were able to empower
you to kind of move to the next steps in
Cloud
thank you so much thank you
so next we have uh Manish parihar from
pgp in full stack development
ish
hello can you okay yes I can I can hear
you as well sir okay uh great
um
I mean I I've been a actor in my life
for about eight to nine years and then I
decided to switch over to it as a career
and uh it was uh kind of a mid careers
you know midlife career change uh very
tough very challenging but and I would
really uh thank at this time simply
learned which really helped me you know
Propel my career as a as a full stack
dive first and uh then I enrolled for
the uh Cloud program
and I'm glad that I did that
um uh with with Caltech Association it
was kind of a no-brainer to go with
simply learn and I'm really thankful to
the entire team for putting up this uh
this uh very valuable uh program
it uh you know the The Faculty were
quite considerate the project uh based
learning really helped and uh the master
classes by Dr John and Dr Patrick were
you know simply uh eye-opening and you
know they really opened up New
Dimensions so uh
uh like I I am I'm very confident that
you know uh that the role that simple
Learners played uh in in getting me
started from scratch in an industry you
know uh when I was like really fumbling
and you know to this to this day when
you know I I'm kind of acting the uh as
a tech lead for full stack and now also
uh working in Cloud environments uh you
know for for some projects and all it
really gives me the confidence to go out
there and and uh and play the role and
in fact it it did help in my current
project as well I was uh you know chosen
to be a part of the architect team as
well which was working on cloud
migration and uh you know so so the
content was you know kind of really
helped me
um uh like on the Fly I I was learning
it I was applying it I was discussing
you know with colleagues with Shakib and
you know a few others it was absolutely
fun uh absolutely exciting I really look
forward
to you know do few more a couple of more
programs which simply learn and uh I I
think uh this has been a great value add
and uh you know for for people like me
who've kind of decided to take uh such a
risk and uh you know leaving a
full-fledged career in in an absolutely
unrelated industry switching over to
another one and you know uh trying to
gain uh football and and you know Mark
presence in in an exciting industry like
like it uh uh I think these kind of
programs are out of place and uh I've
been really fortunate to have completed
this and yes
pointed out the weekends have been
growing
all right it's been tiring uh but but it
you know when when you submit your
project and you receive a good feedback
which is uh relevant to you on
submission you really feel uh you know
it uh veins off and you know the fatigue
wins off and you really see yourself
much more properly in advance than your
in your own understanding in your own
career and now I have the confidence to
uh to approach multi-cloud to approach
uh architect paradigms you know with
with much more clarity and uh uh and and
a much higher ambition for microservices
scalable architectures and things like
that so it has made my world much worse
my uh path much clearer and uh thanks to
Simply learn and thanks to Celtic uh you
know with whomever I shared the
certificate of completion uh they really
congratulated me and you know uh I think
uh it's because of names like Cal taken
intensive dealer behind it so thanks to
the entire team for putting up this and
uh I'm surely preparing for uh I'm
targeting something for for another next
year as well and and these
certifications uh and uh the cloud
specific certifications would follow
next that is that is what I feel uh you
know uh I mean that's what put me my
next immediate next steps uh thanks
again sorry if it went a lot thanks we
are so glad to hear your success stories
and we are so glad that you're able to
kind of put all your learnings into
projects immediately right so that is
the great takeaway
thank you so much money for sharing your
thoughts
okay now it's uh time to celebrate
success uh it's time to honor each and
every one who has completed their PG
program with us would like to give you
all a very quick uh snippet of the
number of qualified Learners here we
have around 71 Learners from 11 cohorts
qualified for devops an astonishing 260
Learners from 30 cohorts qualified for
cloud computing and we have 21 Learners
from four co-ops who are qualified for
full stack development
now moving on to the felicitation of all
graduates I would like to apologize
before proceeding uh because I may not
pronounce all the names right so please
bear with me and in case we missed out
any names please do not panic it wasn't
intentional please feel free to reach
out to us and we will accommodate you in
the next convocation ceremony
we will get started with devops
we have shapur
ayush ashwani Ankit shamik
Michael sanuj Adolfo Anil satyasip
Siddharth
many congratulations learners
we have pankaj
Garrett purushottam Erica
Johan
Shai
jasna Raju Balaji
Akash Benjamin Tina
widows everyone many congratulations
we have nothing
Rakesh Manoj Anthony raghav Rajesh Ahmed
Rakesh Darlene
Rachel
Rukia
helson Sanjeev saranya
Selva Felipe Cameron
Tariq
Ganesh Timothy
Chris
Vishnu
Khalil pramod
yashdev
yavdesh sorry Deepa Ajay Krishna
akhilesh jojin
many congratulations learners
we have Kapil Farooq Avinash
Ma
Muhammad Mustafa bent
Edward
chandrika
Ajay
ferdos
gajala and Majid many congratulations
all graduates from pgp devops we're so
proud of you
next we move on to pgp and cloud
computing
we have mirnul
shiv Krishna dinkar Nippon
Leo lipolio
Muhammad
Varun Priyanka srinivasan shikib Amit
vinaya
many congratulations everyone
we have suhalia Krishnan Kumar
venkateshan Sandeep Nikita nitin
Rakesh yahai Rajiv
videos to everyone
we have Kapil Suresh Muhammad Mustafa
Krishna devanjali
Kota
kundal
a Tanika
Thompson
corn
and stagger many congratulations
everyone
we have shubham
foreign
Deva durgesh Ganesh Adolfo Tanya sriji
balachandra Rahul
Jyoti
many congratulations
we have vineet Anthony arpan Aruna Ankit
anudeep
foreign
we have Saleem foreign
and Anderson
close to everyone
we have Manish champlala champalal
um
Prashant Sunil kamaldeep alexandris
nitendra
many congratulations everyone
we have aprajita Amit
srinivas srinivas
tennis Lakshmi
Farina and Vishal
many congratulations and Kudos everyone
Muhammad zubair Manoj buddy
Vishal
Hassan
vishwesh venkatesh Vignesh vikas vesco
krutika
viraraman rishikesh vaishali Gonzalo
anupam Vishal cherica
Muhammad
Ajit Kumar Sunita surbhi Carlos
Suresh Anjali Angelia
many congratulations everyone
we have thousand
sukriti Philip sourav sonil sujit Sunday
subash Jude Joseph Stephen
Joseph
revelia
kemchon
Sundar song Dan Soma shaker said I said
Helena ashitosh
Siva prakash
Deepak
wine long
Satish
Shahid Shankar minu Kumari madhava
Karthik and Shankar for those in many
congratulations
foreign
making it Naji murlider
shivata shweta Benson Omar Ashish Nargis
narasimha Karthik Eric Buddha Kumar Omar
trade him neeraj Nathan Nathan Neil
Mohammed sufian luas Carlos
nitin
Prashant
the name
shravani giant Priti ogor pratima
many congratulations
we have raghav Rahman Mukesh hitesh binu
Benny
ranjini Rajiv Rakesh Mark Rober rajendra
Rhythm ritesh Robert
Durga
darshan
Daryl
Abdullah name
pushpal public
Shilpa
many congratulations article
collaborations everyone
we have Vignesh
Arun
Daniel sachindra America Viber
only
faizen Eric
ayush Philippe darshan Brian
on one
amul
Eric
Mendoza and haridanda many
congratulations to everyone who have
graduated in post-graduate program in
cloud computing
many many many congratulations
now we have our graduates from pgp in
full stack web development
we have submit
Azad breedna Ramya suming Xavier
Prashant
kensan swapnil many congratulations
we have rohini poem
arshad
Wilfred
sonali
maninder Theodore John
Andrea Samuel and Brian
many congratulations everyone so excited
for you guys to finish the program
all right
thank you so much and many many
congratulations again everyone for
graduating in your respective programs
now we all know that you are all
Achievers since this journey is
something which is not very easy but
there are few Learners who went a Step
Beyond and displayed their competitive
Spirit we have two sectors of our plan
for the evening the first category of
award is the scholar award
here we feel State top two performers in
each category in terms of completing
their live classes projects and
assessments with the highest cumulative
scores
first I would like to call out the
scholars from postgraduate program in
devops we have Tina Kamali who have
scored 87.80 and we have at also who
have scored 86.5 so if Adolfo or Trina
whoever else are there if you could
share a few insights about how you did
this will be great
hey Adolfo I see you there
yes we can hear you
yes
good
um no
the great experience
I believe that that effort that we put
into it
um the time that we spent the sacrifices
of the weekends
then not the knights that we didn't
sleep
um
the sharing with our colleagues several
times that we were focused on what
additional resources we needed to have
to to complete the tasks the different
projects
um completing actually are disciplined
in terms of knowing which projects were
key for us in in terms of challenging
projects that could give us a better
understanding of the children that we
were learning and also
um sometimes I believe that the practice
that we have
um in addition in our work put in those
those
skills and those toolings being applied
at our everyday work are very important
for for these achievements
yep thank you so much Adolfo for the
insights and many congratulations again
for uh getting the scholar award
thank you thank you thank you so moving
on to uh cloud computing next
so we have Sunil Kumar balakrishna who
has scored 88.3 and we have sham Sundar
Mulkey who has code 88.8
so if Asha or Sunil if anyone is
available in the crowd we would like to
really hear it from you
I can see you soon
can you unmute yourself
hello
yes I can hear you hi good evening good
morning and good night many of them want
different time zone yeah yeah it was a
very wonderful uh structured and
find course and I would appreciate
Caltech and simply learn to to prepare
the curriculum in such a way that it was
very easy for for a weekend classes so
it was very live interactive class so
that that really interactive classes
really helped to to attend the class
even though uh as many participants said
it was a weekend family so so it was it
was really helpful when we get a
feedback from the the tutor itself and
it was very helpful from the tutors to
have an interactive classes and clear
the doubts on on any of the topics
related in the the curriculum so it was
very wonderful uh it was great to have
have the scholar uh our also in this and
I really appreciate sibling Caltech to
prepare the course in such a way to for
the participants to attend it thank you
very much thanks all uh all the things
and congratulate all the all the what
expense here thank you thank you so much
Sunil and many congratulations again
so now we move on to uh full stack one
of the toughest tracks and uh Brian
Daniel has scored 96 an astonishing 96
and we have Ken sang who has scored 95.4
just behind uh Brian many
congratulations both of you if anyone is
available to speak would be great to
hear from you
I can see you there again
can can you unmute yourself yes
we are not able to hear you can to
speaking
Ken if you're speaking we are not able
to hear you sorry
all right no problem no problem
thank you so much Ken uh and many
congratulations you can share your
insights on the chat as well so we'll be
there to uh
people will be really interested to see
how we did it many congratulations again
so uh thank you for sharing all your
experience with us uh Now we move on to
the second set of awards uh which
recognizes Learners who are able to
complete the program end to end in the
shortest duration we call them the
speedrunners again we start with pgp
devops we have uh strainivas who has
completed the course at a record 94 days
and we have Ankit shanpuria Westco who
has completed the course in 159 days
many congratulations both of you
if anyone is available to speak would be
great
all right so moving on
so from pgp cloud computing we have uh
pritik Mari who has done it in 91 days
and we have Pierre Anderson who has done
it in 92 days many congratulations both
of you
many many congratulations
and if anyone is available to speak
would be great to hear from you
how you did it
right
okay uh so the last program in pgp FSD
we have maninder real
who has completed it at a record time of
164 days and we have Prashant Kal Shetty
who has done it in 166 days many
congratulations both of you
if maninder or prashanth if anyone is
available
okay
there is no one available I guess all
right many congratulations again with us
and again everyone here is an achiever
just one step uh they are just one step
ahead that's it
thank you everyone
is available
to speak can you move on to the panelist
yes please please I would like to hear
Shakib to speak yes thank you
should keep if you're here
yes I can see on the banned list yes
Audible
yes you are
you all right I'm sorry about the you
want to add some audio issues
good afternoon good evening to everyone
and uh a huge congratulations to all the
all the people who have completed the
different courses and the Toppers uh for
standing out uh and and making Denmark
uh so quick intro on me my name is Khan
I have a work experience of 15 years in
technology for sale radius alone with my
current role I basically design and
build Cloud contacts in the solutions
using Amazon connect as a service
my learning experience with simply learn
it's it's been like a wonderful Journey
actually
I didn't expect when when I stopped when
I joined the course I didn't expect the
journey to go like this but the way the
course came in it was so precise it was
so helpful and I I really have to call
out the latch specifically
the type of labs that have been provided
because I have seen other courses also
but the labs provided here by simply
learn and Caltech were just amazing I
didn't I didn't expect the lab to be of
such good quality and giving so much of
exposure where we can in fact build
almost anything that we want to and then
we tear it down right so that was
definitely something that's that stood
out
and uh I was able to use the learnings
and improve the the work that I do bring
in more efficiency more productivity so
thank you again for that and uh uh I I
want to definitely call out all the
instructors great instructors who are
very helpful but uh Mr Puri showed them
whom we used to call Mr puru was was
some was someone who really uh I I
admire he was very knowledgeable he
knows how to engage the audience and
always made sure that we are we are
completely involved into the program so
a big thanks to Mr Peru and all the
learning success managers the simply
learned team whenever I have reached out
to them with any concern any problem
they have made sure that the problem is
resolved so thank you very much simply
learn team and I am definitely looking
forward to join more courses and uh soon
you will hear from me for the next
courses as well again thank you for
giving me this opportunity a big thanks
to everyone and congratulations again
thank you
thank you so much it was great uh to
listen to your success stories and uh
many congratulations again thank you so
much
all right
so apart from the graduates who shared
their experience with us like Shakib did
uh we also would like to thank you all
for actively reviewing us on social
media platforms time and now so we are
super happy and excited to have all your
feedbacks put in different social media
platforms and appreciation of our
program we have also received feedbacks
which has made us work harder fix a lot
of things and move forward to making
sure that you have a better learning
experience
so uh with that we move on to the team
behind the scenes so now I would like me
to introduce you all to the team behind
the scenes who work relentlessly to make
sure that you have the best of learning
experience the idea behind this is to
put a face to the names you have heard
and interacted with in the last one year
first I would like to introduce our
faculty team
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank our faculty for constantly
supporting us throughout the program
they have been the major pillars for
your experience and would like to call
out each faculty and thank them on your
behalf
we have uh purushottam naresh jigar
ashitosh Granger
abhijeet
ayush Wahid gurpreet Sebastian Praveen
gitika
we have vinod Akash Pawan
Amit Aman sonal Varun
thank you so much faculties for being
there with uh with the Learners and
guiding them
at the right path uh if you have any
faculty here it would be uh great to
hear from them as well
we have Dr gitika
yes could you uh to mute yourself yes
yes
okay hi and so you want me to speak do
you want to give me a chance to speak
I'll be grateful for that thank you okay
hi everybody uh warm wishes and I my
speech is going to be a little bit
longer because there's a lot to be
talking about sharing experiences and
lot many people to be thanking me so
please bear with me so first of all bone
wishes it is a pleasure to come here
learn and Learners to celebrate the
completion and success of this
challenging Journey that we all almost
you know undertook together so I would
like to thank simple learn and
especially the backend team and my
account manager Eamon for inviting me
here to speak and I'm honored to be here
actually to be sharing my thoughts and
uh gratitude with all of you and many
congratulations to each one of you for
this momentous achievement and you and
your families should be proud of what
you you have accomplished and you're
entering into one of the most exciting
Fields uh that is uh that is existing
the world today which is I'm in cloud
computing so I'm a cloud computing
faculty so I would say for that but I'm
sure the other feels like devops that
is just here and uh we have other uh the
other wonderful stack development also
guys I'm sure you are also you've also
had an exciting time so I would talk
about cloud computing as we all know has
been addressed as the champion of the
information age and the participants uh
like Manish also said this is a baseline
right no matter whatever courses you are
going to get into or you've already
accomplished this is the Baseline this
offers you plethora of services and
indeed it is hard to find uh you know a
modern company that does not store an
accessibility in the cloud so keep
bringing the long story short uh This
Cloud Computing can be a major career
revolutionizing Catalyst and such a
journey is very well deserved to be
taken through this Caltech CDMA program
in collaboration with simply run
and simply one has made a big difference
in my life as well like all of you
shared your experiences uh being a
faculty member of the Celtic PhD program
it has allowed me to join a you know
dynamic industry and to work uh for one
of the best at tech companies in the
world which is simply done and I'm so
grateful uh in the spirit of Celebration
I want to wish all the Learners an
impactful cloud computing journey and
also wish each one of you much success
and ability to impact many lives
congratulations once again everybody
thank you so very much thank you Naveen
and thank you everybody
yeah all right
we're just checking if uh
we have another trainer
who would uh like to speak
we have uh
purushottam
yes hello everyone everyone's favorite
thank you thank you very much yeah so
thank you thank you Naveen for giving me
this opportunity yes guys so first of
all I would like to thank uh everybody
simply learn Caltech for inviting me to
this program to share my experience uh
let me tell you it's it's it's being a
great honor for me to be associated with
such a pride University and simply learn
to deliver training program on Azure
architect Azure administrator
uh my experience has been amazing so far
as I keep learning from many students
many Learners as it keeps me on my toes
many times uh let me tell you too and
and it encourages me to keep researching
and deliver my best to the learner
Community I'm feeling privileged to
speak over here and it's being one of my
best achievements so far okay uh so I
would like to congratulate all the
Learners and all the Learners community
over here in all the hard work that they
have put forth in achieving this
prestigious certification from Caltech
and simply learn so once again thanks
Caltech thanks simply learn thanks
for providing me this opportunity on a
whole and yeah thanks uh shikib and
everybody for appraising me yeah guys
you have been wonderful and thanks for
giving your time in my classes I know
they were lengthy quite lengthy but uh
you have been like you have kept the
spirit in fact I if you tell you every
time and today also see it's not that
difficult to teach but it's very
difficult to be there and to understand
and to be there for four hours at a
stretch and to listen to the instructor
so heads up to you guys uh you have done
a great job so all the best for your
futures so do well and yeah that is it
from my end thank you
thank you so much
for being here and uh addressing the
crowd
we are getting a lot of messages for
both of you
thank you okay
so moving on so we would uh also like to
thank our Master Class instructors as
everyone would have uh heard from the
people who spoke uh part of the Caltech
family facilitating us with different
interesting topics every month Dr John
witch Eugene Lai Matthew dutris uh
Patrick Alexander Chris Boyston and Dave
tagaru thank you so much for all the
faculties
and moving on to the Core theme at
simply learn so here's the learner's
success team here's the team who's
responsible for all the sessions and
people who resolve the tickets that you
pose many would have interacted with
them directly or indirectly so we have
uh Aryan Manoj Arun Hari Nilesh kruti
Imran Sagar rithwik jagat
that is me we have madurama Abhishek
Lucy and nitin
thank you so much much learn a success
team for helping everyone
next we have the faculty and Alignment
team
uh the faculty and Alignment team is
responsible for hand picking and getting
us the best of trainers so uh thank you
so much Ayman and Mohammed qasim
so next we have the product team so this
team is the brain behind curating the
program and structuring it so they have
been the bridge between simply learning
Celtic and the drivers of the program we
have Abhishek Jain Mayan tiwari and
Anand kaswan
next we have the content team the team
which is responsible for all the content
and curriculum that we see in terms of
live virtual classes as well as
self-learning videos we have rajat
Agarwal Ravi tulsiani and sushmita
let's take a moment to thank and applaud
them for all their efforts and thank you
so much team this is internal but yes we
don't get to thank each other
many times so I'd like to take this
moment to thank kashab and Mike for
being there uh all the way for the
convocation many many thanks for YouTube
being there till the end
and uh it just brings us to the end of
our third edition of online convocation
for uh postgraduate program with Caltech
ctme in association with uh simply learn
we wish each and every uh every graduate
all the very best for their future and
we believe being aspirational is the
first part of being successful and you
have come here with an aspiration and
dream and we are pretty sure many of you
will excel in different streams of your
career
with that
um we want you to leave with one thought
today you are now our ambassadors for
caltex ctme uh simply learn PG programs
people will follow you and your
footsteps and you will be there guiding
life to success so we would request you
to be active in our in your community in
our communities and post some
interesting topics for future Learners
and also keep us posted about your
success stories and tag us so that we
can also celebrate as well as set the
right path for the future Learners as
well once again it's a heartfelt
gratitude from us for you choosing
simply learn to be your partner to skill
up thank you once again everyone for
making time for this even good night
good day and good luck everyone thank
you so much
thank you everyone who joined today
thank you thank you thank you
so we will take any questions if uh
there is any
um yes the recordings will be shared
again and it is already streaming live
in YouTube and Linkedin as well
question to Master Class instruction
a book list a reading list yeah
yeah
let's put that together
sure yeah
yes we will have everyone uh we'll have
the hard copy document reach out to
everyone and uh we will work with
Caltech in uh getting the physical
certificate so we were waiting for the
convocation to end so that we have uh
the entire list of Learners so that we
can do it in uh one shot
yes everyone will get a hard copy
whoever is interviewed for it yes okay
there are certificates were running a
little bit behind yes yes
wrestler shirt Mike is here everyone is
here uh we will get yes it will be
delivered in India it will be delivered
to your home address
yes worldwide
yep
we'll come up with a reading list and
and share that and as I mentioned
earlier the circle membership nodes will
go out
um
I think this week four is September
probably in two weeks for October
yes transcripts will be shared
yeah
over your email yes
program yes if you are enrolled for it
we can we can definitely help you out
with the Services Program as well
you can reach out to us via tickets and
we'll help you out
so that is normal messages
so thank you everyone for joining uh do
you need to opt for physical certificate
yes we will send out uh an uh a form and
you can fill that form and uh we can
facilitate that shouldn't be a problem
I'll take Traders yes you will see that
as well if your letter of completion
will have the CEUs listed yes
you can raise a ticket as well actually
for uh the pad copy yeah that can also
be done not a problem in facial data
once you raise the ticket you will uh
receive your message with a with a link
and uh you can fill in the fill in the
details and once we have the details we
will share them with Caltech and you
will get your certificates in in two to
three months time yes as Mike said we
are running a little behind so we will
get we'll get that facilitated everyone
who's enrolled and who's eligible will
definitely get the physical certificates
into the question about how the the
credits work those are not
Caltech credits necessarily but these
are continuing education credits so the
program is accredited to document the
number of hours invested in active
learning and then you use these with
your employer to document uh
professional development time and
sometimes substantiate your learning uh
if you have tuition reimbursement
solutions for program Improvement yes
you can share your comments uh in the
emails as well as the tickets that is
not a problem yeah we are we are here to
kind of improve the program yeah please
provide feedback yes please do
and the circle membership uh will be
accessed to some Caltech events news
about other programs uh it is for all
the certificate holders
so it's a little Community Network of
of Caltech
and we're and that will be growing as
well so we have some new things coming
up
made for master classes we'll check that
out yeah you can reach us tickets and
yes we will tell you the upcoming
schedule shouldn't be a problem
cell phone images are access to Simply
learn will work after training period or
will it be reboot no it will be there
the self-learning videos will be there a
lifetime
and congratulations again
there's yeah there's not a uh
matriculation to a master's program
but you can send me a note on that if
you'd like
starting with kind of Dick triplets does
it mean that would place the credits
they
um there won't work there's as I said
with Thompson uh there's not a path to
join the master's program or be
Caltech does not have a lot of Masters
terminal master's degrees
it's more of a PhD
Institute degree granting our programs
are just certificates the correct
continuing education credits help you
with your employer and and substantiate
your learning
right
okay how do we get more information
about Caltech PhD Mike go to caltech.edu
uh look under graduate education
and you can learn about the different
programs there
your those continuing education credits
and depending on the number of any
electives that you did
um
those will be on a letter of completion
which will come along with your
certificate in email
and especially your agent for that like
to get into accounting Masters program
yeah the
um
as we've mentioned there's uh
the the credits work differently
but if you want to pursue Masters or a
PhD check out caltech.edu
if you want to cover the bonafide
we don't have any bona fide as such uh
but sham you can um you can write to us
and we can get what kind of a Bonafide
certificate targeting phone because
there would be some later
that sort of acceptance kind of thing
that you might be looking for so we
really want to understand the context so
you can write to us that's not a problem
we'll connect with you and we'll get
that sorted
I think in the brochure on the site
uh bona fide certificate was always
listed
for for Indian Nationals
I think at this point I'm going to drop
yes thank you so much Mike for being
there till the end and uh thank you so
much and thanks everyone for being here
and many congratulations all the all the
Learners again thank you so much Mike
good to see you thank you thank you for
putting this together this is great
thank you so much yeah bye take care
thank you everyone
take care bye